18h heure de sortie des bureaux et heure
de pointe sur les routes Sylvie masuchi
assistante travaux chez Bouygues
Construction à Guyancourt se dirige vers
le parking de l'entreprise direction les
places réservées au covoiturage depuis
la mi-janvier sylvie a décidé qu'elle ne
voyagerait plus seul dans son véhicule
en premier lieu pour une question
cruciale par ces temps de crise côté
financier essentiellement ensuite on
voit la le fait de pas faire le trajet
tout seul c'est 60 km c'est quand même
seul c'est quand même assez long donc
c'est quand même assez agréable de
pouvoir discuter avec les gens et non ça
se passe bien mais c'est surtout le côté
financier au départ
guyancourtreux 67 km le quotidien de
Sylvie au sein de son entreprise elle a
trouvé trois autres collègues qui
pratiquent le covoiturage depuis
septembre 2012
Sylvie Pothier également employé chez
Bouygues Construction fait partie de
l'équipe dans l'emploi du temps de
chacune s'il faut s'adapter par rapport
à une absence des congés on fait des
échanges mais en règle générale c'est
une semaine chacune à l'instar de
Bouygues Construction d'autres
entreprises de l'agglomération
encouragent le covoiturage c'est le cas
du groupe Malakoff Médéric ici aussi les
emplacements sont réservés pour les
covoitureurs mais le concept peine
malgré tout à démarrer c'est vraiment un
état d'esprit une question de mentalité
les gens ont du mal à s'accaparer l'idée
qu'on peut covoiturer qu'on peut voyager
à deux ou à trois c'est pas encore
rentré dans nos mœurs mais faut pas
désespérer la preuve nos deux Sylvie ne
renonceraient au covoiturage pour rien
au monde